you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens welcome back ladies and
gentlemen to the game spot live show
here at e3 2016 before we get started
with our final segment I like to
announce the winner of today's lego star
wars the force awakens contests that
winners name is Tim ass from Portland
congratulations Tim the answer that Tim
gave to the tell us your favorite moan
for the Star Wars awakened force awakens
question was when Han tells Finn that's
not how it works when he's asking about
the force this is a nice like young
young and you need you need to get
learned uh Tim wins a Lego Millennium
Falcon and the copy of lego star wars
force awakens for the platform of his
choice congrats buddy all right I
clapped already boom clap yeah that's
cool ladies and gentlemen Chris waters
here with Joe and shire sohinki and
lasercorn on the game spot III co-op
stage we are wrapping up III 2016 by
talking about III 2017 because e3 2016
is over it old news I'm done God was it
or not even here anymore murder them
indeed out worried in an empty studio
there's no one here hits I it's a dead
it's a dead zone but I looking ahead to
next year let's talk about some
predictions things that we think will
come true you can some wishful thinking
in here totally acceptable we can go
through sort of platform by flat form
but there's a joint of you have
something salient what do you think will
be Jones are you been talking about the
theme of EV yeah i think that theme of
next year every III think this was the
like so many games for the current
consoles that we've already head out vr
is kind of out of the way but with the
major announcements of scorpio and me
neo i think we're that fully next year's
going to be the the what-is-it the the
new could hold the console year yeah
danx as well yes well we will probably
get that then right not before or do you
think we'll get NX before e3 2017 ooh
that's that's that's a hard one i think
that
okay so with consoles right what do you
what do you need to do you need to you
need to have something exciting to show
you need to convince people like yeah
I'm gonna spend another couple hundo on
this thing yes I'm excited about the
future so for that you need not just the
console to look good have good specs but
you need the games as well I feel like
it might be a little soon to show it
ahead of time and then have like a big
event next year 83 I feel like if eat
next year's e3 is hey here's the Scorpio
here's what it's really called hey
here's the you know I think hey here's
the NX and we have these games for it I
think we'll probably hear about the Neo
ps4 ahead of time ahead of next year's
e3 because it's the only one that like
hasn't really been tangibly talked about
as much here's a here's my wishful
thinking 33 2070 now we're seeing like
project Scorpio it's essentially a PC
they're coming even have a keyboard and
a mouse peripheral coming out for the
xbox mm-hmm so we're seeing things sort
of unify a bit we have the xbox play
anywhere stuff you can play your games
on your pc and your xbox and maybe you
can play anywhere even on a ps4 or the
next playstation here's what i want to
see cross-platform real cross-platform
unity everyone being able to play
anything very far away from that
anywhere how does that work in your
minds so do you just because you're like
alrighty say you want to play a god of
war on your ex bone are you subscribing
to us playstation plus and that's what
allows you access to it are you getting
a disc that you know it's an ultra-high
blu-ray in the in the driver and i don't
even know that this is necessarily you
know the way it has to be but i think in
the future the only reason that you
would pick an Xbox machine over a sony
playstation machine is the exclusives
but then any game like all of duty or
something that's a call of duty or a
street fighter 5 like those can be
played on multi platforms that'd be
great have you gotten war on ps4 have
your halo on on xbox but i'm with you i
don't think we're very far away for
them people just being able to have
really cross platform their motto be
actually play anywhere it's catchy yeah
I uh we've been seeing a lot of
remastered games and we've been seeing
the VR trend I'm gonna say it I don't
know if it'll actually happen but what
might be cool for 2017 and we started
seeing old games come into VR like I
always thought like twisted metal two
would be really cool in VR just to see
like mr. smash coming at you or should
the shadow thing racing along the ground
videos I see the window shatter and so I
even played a driving game in VR yeah
yeah have you get might be cool right no
I uh can't be too much different from
the pilot me get you in it you deny it
but there was that extension of the
heist thing oh yeah we are where you're
in the car or even a new twisted metal
for vro what I'm thinking is I mean
would a car crash in VR mess you up
below would it be traumatic you probably
had some get some feeling I'm on it you
got to push the envelope you know
marriage is to say like the kills in you
mentioned kill zone they were too
intense when you're couching people's
eyes out and stuff and like we've moved
past it so they might be like oh the car
crashes are too intent we're gonna have
enough of that yeah yeah you're not
galvanized out in every game now what
most didn't become a thing that's true
well I don't know there's some pretty
vicious stuff in the new doom do you get
how do you go just yet room III think
definitely realistically how these go is
like we'll get the major announcements
and then we'll see more of it this year
and I so I think all the major
announcements this year we're obviously
going to see more of next year if mass
effect doesn't make it out before e3
next year which part of me wonders if it
will I think we'll actually see real
gameplay and it's something great but
more importantly is going to be EA I
think EA hopefully they learn from this
year and I think they are going to have
a great show Star Wars wise I think neck
up next year's theme is going to be Star
Wars yep because they didn't show us
anything from battlefront 2 which has
already been stated to come out next
year oh yeah well they did mention that
it'll have content from the new movie
a new movies which what stood before the
shed again here they really didn't give
us a lot they did say that visceral now
has a game coming out in 2018 yes so I
think we're going to see battlefronts
game we receive this rolls game we're
gonna I I I think respawn entertainment
reasons gonna have their game I think EA
is gonna steal it next year with Star
Wars because man they told us they were
going through there like we have such
cool star wars things here we can't show
you any more info later one of my
biggest disappointments and one of my
another wishful thinking thing on the
Star Wars tip is when Star Wars 1313 got
cancelled I was the saddest gamer of all
time the saddest I wanted to see that
game so a little early for a bit yeah oh
my god you find out it was gonna be a
boba fett game afterwards yes like and
like look Jedi's are cool and everything
but they're not the most interesting
thing about the star wars universe to me
there's a lot and cool stuff going on
there as evidence by how much Disney is
sort of putting into you know yea r 0 or
1 rocks for edible so good that's Taylor
I Star Wars news i totally agree is
gonna be big at next year's e3 but i
also think we're gonna hear about a lot
of it beforehand at Star Wars
celebrations yeah that's that I think is
becoming a bigger and bigger event as
star war now however than ever before
with Disney owning everything having a
new Star Wars movie every single year I
wouldn't when is that normally is that
an that's an earlier in the year event
isn't it literally went to it last year
and I'm yeah I think it's in the spring
yeah in Anaheim it but then they also
have one in London I believe that
there's yet been moving around Star Wars
gonna be there in a big way Mass Effect
I mean it better be there but here's my
question about EA this year at e3 EA did
not have a boost on the show floor
mm-hmm EA did a press conference and
then they had EA play at a venue near
the LA Convention Center this was a
place where you can you know show off
your games to the public yes right right
and public people can come in II you
know III is an industry event what do we
think about eat hat do you think EA will
continue with that approach
vol vit in any way in terms of their
presence at e3 I I think that's a really
good point and I think that's just III
growing as a convention because
traditionally it has been a industry
event yeah it's been opened up to the
public once or twice didn't really work
as a little been predicting like oh the
next year is going to be here they
reopen it to the public OB the neck I
think this is the way to do it because
we have EA you have the the doritos area
over at nokia live where it's open to
all these different games and i think
that's a great way to do it it's
literally III impacts at the same time
yeah so you might not walk into the
doors but at this one time do you need
to walk into III I agree I I know and
here's my here's my bold prediction EA
expands that and makes it like or
another pup makes it a big weekend fan
fest before e3 leading into it they do
some of us things they do their press
conference it sort of feeds into III but
they get all their big news and impact
on the weekend preceding this is
something I do not want to happen
because I don't want to be in la
covering III four more days oh my god
yeah well I think that you know they see
the power of the power of e3 is getting
people to talk about your games one of
the best ways to do that is to get them
to get some hands on the games yeah one
of the present what I would like to see
is fallout with Bethesda it's so great
last year I thought they did the
smartest thing ever where they blew us
away with the Bob for announcement but
even bigger than that was hey it comes
out in three months yeah where's that at
we're worth any of the release titles
this year there were a few i'll go get
everything so there's a few sure like at
the end of Mass Effect I'm like where's
the release date all right and I gotta
where is the release date Legend of
Zelda where's the release date that's
the new thing have release dates fallout
4 I like you a lot of these days pls but
yeah yet you also have those games that
yeah how early is too early to announce
you know you got horizon zero dawn it
slipped a little bit do you get mad when
games are delayed these days or how do
you feel about it I I don't think I get
mad when games are delayed especially
when it looks like it was for a good
reason for honored was delayed and then
we find out that there's this massive
single-player campaign that they've
it's when games get delayed again yeah
and then they get delayed again that's
when you start questioning what's going
on then you hear these rumors coming out
that like oh the director of the game's
been having a problem with the publisher
and it's all messy and yeah the first
delay i'm just like it's probably for a
good reason you know massive equity fall
2016 and then moved to first quarter of
2017 and I thought I thought 2016 was
ambitious in the first place so I saw
that I was like yeah want the game to be
good oh wait yeah okay oh oh wait ok I
don't want to be dangling I don't be
dangling here with these great games you
like just it's so close we're getting
some information cuz that's what III
needs to be III is about information
bring your the best information you got
give it to the public and let him go
wild with it I have a have another
wishlist item let's do it for 2017 so
there was a game that everyone was very
excited for it was cancelled and then
this year we saw game trailer we didn't
see any gameplay or anything is starring
Norman Reedus oh yeah ended a stranding
stranding yeah excuse me and no one
really knows exactly what this is
anybody have tell from the title because
the ending that we know that Norman
Reedus is naked amongst a bunch of fish
there was a baby there was a baby they
all yep and they got a bit I yeah enemy
some sky things look maybe Konami
realizes they messed up maybe we see
silent hill that's what I want oh if you
want to Silent Hill it's not you know
it's not like a new arena sitting there
drinking his puff of Konami tears yeah
maybe I realizing all right all right
resident evil seems to jump in and kind
of filled yeah that's true space if you
look at the the silent Hills BTW and the
the resident evil trailer kind of a
little similarities going on it's creepy
it feels almost more like a Silent Hill
game than a Resident Evil game at least
one of the newer one yeah so yeah maybe
they come back maybe they're like ah
damn they're gonna qui mix can we gotta
get out there yeah it could be I really
want to see more about death stranding a
huge even said it's not going to be a
horror game so hopefully by III 2017
we've know more about the game and we
see where it's going I swear those guys
this guy
I feel like we gotta know that I don't
be resolved five situation on our hands
yeah it's like des trending but then the
actual game titles is revealed two years
from now and then actually turns out to
be a mental phenomena oh yeah that's
good news thanks full circle that did
tommy was inside Hong Kong until they
can somehow get the rights to melody
solid snake was like this is gaseous
snake gas to say yeah Norman Reedus says
yeah the move through all the elements
yeah all right here's a question yeah
sony has the PlayStation VR do we think
that Microsoft with project Scorpio is
going to be and their you know their
relationship with oculus are they going
to be getting into VR next year at e3
hmm that's a really good question i
think they'd be silly if they didn't
yeah they think they do have their AR
headset which I thought it was very
smart that they didn't mention because
right now every be our department is
trying to be different than the others
so to say we're actually different
because we're AR I think you get lost in
all the news I think it was smart that
they didn't mention anything this year I
think we could see something from
Microsoft BR wise next year maybe
they're waiting for PlayStation to see
how it works and I thought make any
mistakes Amell do something better also
on that note I would like to see more
news about the hololens we had a very
early version and we tried it out and it
it's it's cool it's right I would like
to see the expansion of that maybe that
little screen gets expanded to be the
actual size of the visor and that would
be like the logistical challenges for
our the programming challenges for
augments reality for those hollow lens
things to bring it beyond that small
field of you are like astronomical yeah
that sounds like a Microsoft teams up
with google google glasses into hololens
to giants working together we win there
we go let's boomers baby what since I'm
here what is the practical application
of AR though in like making games does
it how does it practical no
nothing crack I'm really cool yeah yes
being able to have a computer screen
here on this wall but like be able to
look over here and on this wall is
Netflix it also have natural light still
be able to enter your eyes imagine
imagine I playing a game of the culling
I know you love the color you enjoy the
gun we could just have that scoreboard
you can move it it's like boom let's put
the scoreboard over here now I get
absolutely chowin now when I look alive
you guys aren't a question that is the
practical i also i don't hate trying to
find the freaking scoreboard enough and
yeah you never know where it is the sons
of times there's a tree in my way have
them in a building but with you with
hololens i don't think we're to see a
lot of gaming um elements to it i think
they'll had they have the relationship
with the oculus i think next year we'll
see more of that with them see that's my
thought on it yeah all right let's talk
about the folks across the way here
Nintendo Reggie mentioned the NX you
know that console is definitely being
developed that's happening they're gonna
Nintendo has taken us you know sort of
an approach lately of doing Nintendo
Direct yes you know they are not they're
not painting all their hopes that
information downloaded III yeah they
didn't do a press conference day but at
the same time they did a nintendo direct
and let's remember when the play state
know the playstation for the first time
we saw that was its own presentation
outside before e3 so I'm thinking we see
the NX in a substantial way yeah for e3
I do too because and I agree only
because of the release rumors of the new
Legend of Zelda being available on Wii U
and on NX what they did with twilight
princess was they released it on we
first which was a new console yeah and
then a month or two later was the
gamecube release so will they do it at
the same time will they do maybe NX
won't be ready maybe we'll get the wii u
release and then a game of the year
edition on NX one that gets released I
think I i like them doing the twilight
princess thing again Legend of Zelda to
Goose the sales and then of the new
console and then you put it on the way
you so people can't say that we you
never had
new Zelda yeah even though it gone up
didn't you know here's here's the
question I have it's a little weird
because this console is coming out
pretty quickly in comparison to other
consoles after the wii u came out well
certainly given you know the ex bought
the wii xbox 360 playstation 3
generation was so long yeah it looks
like we're coming back to a shorter
cycle and so i'm wondering it seems like
we've had a new smash bros game with
every single new nintendo console is it
too early to get another new smash bros
i think they should absolutely launched
with the smash brothers i think part of
the problem with the wii u and y sales
were not great at first was they didn't
have a smash brothers and that's like
their big flagship title that's what
every wants to play their big flagship
title is mario look at real i'm saying
there's gonna be a new mario
announcement fight with that column
situation i'd be interesting you gotta
launch for the mario right i do figure
out they have like well deed do you do a
mario and a link title to sit around the
same time that's almost unprecedented
for nintendo in in recent years yeah i
do think that's what you said I don't I
think honestly these companies are
stepping away from the console
generation because if you look at the
talk with Xbox one to xbox one s to the
Scorpio it's all going to be compatible
it's just an upgraded version what if
we're just up we're like the PlayStation
neo is that going to its is that the
PlayStation five works at the 4.5 what
if they aren't generations anymore
they're just upgrades much like a
computer gets upgraded with time one
thing is clear they've got to do a lot
better job of messaging what exactly
those different iterations are all three
current all three cuz right now I wanted
to get the information out there it's
like you have 4k that we have 4k we've
got Zelda one thing the gas is is making
these really cool names for things and
then making them lame afterwards like
PlayStation VR was project Morpheus
project scorpios is gonna end up being
like new xbox yeah xbox bug you yeah
alright we've talked a lot about the
consoles I want to get into some more
games stuff uh thinking about Ubisoft
all right
they got Ghost Recon wildlands coming
they've got this year and they've got
four honor coming next year let's talk
about the division huge seller for them
wow yeah how to be working on the vision
to do we hear about it at e3 next year I
don't know that game is pretty massive I
think it was unlikely that it would come
out that soon I think it'll be kind of
like a along the lines of destiny where
we didn't get it destiny too we just got
a whole new expansion yeah and they did
talk about those during their press conf
it there's still enough a player base
enough that they can just keep
supporting that the regular game they
don't need to release the sequel I think
that circa I think that's a good call so
yeah I knew we saw predicts gay guy oh
do you guys do now go ahead please I say
another Tom one of their Tom Clancy
franchises comes back yeah so which 1d
I'm thinking which ones are closer Joe
Saunders over you about 6-10 herself we
have twitter so we have an interesting
story not playing with whatever again we
play it sorry we played the the hell out
of splinter cell at one of our first
internet jobs ever we were assigned to
do the coop walkthrough and he had every
single achievement in splinter cell
except for the one where you win the
duel at the end of the coop and he had
already had the g already had it and he
was like you dude let me kill you and I
was like you gotta work for it man no
but more importantly it was my fault
because I was failing the last mission
more times than him and we're there to
like two o'clock the morn trying to
finish he was not going to give me
anything yeah he's not inclined to be a
comedy right the point of the story was
we freaking love splinters yeah like the
co-op has always been great stores like
that like I was kind of sad i didn't get
another one announced this year that's
okay i'll wait till next year i think
that's a good point i think we will all
right ah so let's think about Bethesda
they had their press conference this
year you know we'll be seeing more of
prey and
champion will be seeing you know fallout
in BR and stuff quake champions right
yeah what's next for what a negative as
much as I would love to see it and as
much as everyone would love to see it I
don't think we'll get elder scroll sixth
don't that I I think all these Scrolls
yeah I think it's too soon because
there's some time in between each one of
those I have a weird prediction about
quake ro they've already announced that
quake champions is this like hero
shooter and we're wondering like you
know how is that going to be with quake
and whenever I'm like whenever I try to
describe quake to someone as far as like
what its gonna be as a hero shooter I'm
like I don't know it'll be like bloody
overwatch and then they say oh you mean
lawbreakers I don't know if you've
checked out law breakers at all but it
feels like essentially what that is it's
bloody gory overwatch haha so I have a
feeling that quake is going to end up
having to pivot on their game a little
bit not necessarily stray away from the
hero shooter but they're gonna have to
between now and next year this side what
makes it different and i have a feeling
a lot of that's gonna happen behind the
scenes interested right now especially
after lawbreakers comes out yeah
lawbreakers is coming into alpha pretty
soon and we've got overwatch in full
swing yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna counter
your prediction i think we will see a
new Elder Scrolls game you think so yeah
I think it's time I think it's ready I
think there cuz they're remastering uh
you know sky will get you up yet they
want people to play that again because I
think they want to get you psyched for
what's next I think we will see a new
Elder Scrolls or at least a little
preview a little sneak peek I love 3i
would have perhaps a friendly wager a
friendly five dollar last time we made a
wager I wanted to getting a mohawk
shaved onto my head perhaps a friendly
Mohawk wager tell my like yeah you know
I want you to be right so I'm gonna
agree with you okay all right I don't
like to see the way yeah i mean i'm here
is it not a confident in your prediction
skill no i want to be wrong um I do
think how great would this be because
what Blizzard did with heroes of the
storm which was super brilliant was took
all their franchises and put into an RTS
could you imagine a Bethesda
could you imagine a Bethesda fighting
game you get the Dragonborn versus Corvo
or the quake guy versus the doom guy I'm
sure they have names that's what I want
to see but says and then you know you
got like you got your pip-boy yet
fallout yeah a lot boy it airs your
thumbs up and like the major can watch
version yeah like eating of unlikely
fighting games and and things that
definitely won't happen we had a show
called gamer fights that we're launching
soon and we were talking about who would
be a good person to develop a new mario
game besides nintendo and i went with
nether realm I want to see the brutal
disgusting bloody Mario fighting game
some mario mature is what will get next
year 18 2013 17 crib that's yeah that's
how it's gonna happen speaking of
fighting games we saw injustice you know
we haven't seen is a marble fighting
game and I think it would make more
sense than injustice because in the
Marvel Universe I feel like the
characters are a little more balanced
now are you talking a brand-new morrow
fig up fighting a more like marvel vs
capcom for no i want to see a marvel
fighting like a like an injustice style
game characters from the Marvel Universe
avoiding each other maybe with a story
of what's going on I'd like to see that
I mean I don't know Marvel is not too
big these days they don't have any money
yes it can't possibly it's not like
they've now a ton of heroes that they're
developing in a bunch of different forms
of media right I don't think LASIK oh I
don't think you're very far off because
Marvel did say that spider-man is not
going to be their only video game they
are going to start to expand really big
in the video game verse so maybe we will
team might be the theme might be all
about Marvel yeah maybe they'll create a
video game universe you know crossovers
I'm okay with that I've derailed this we
were talking about developer know where
we're off the rails we're crashing down
the hillside and we're almost done
what's great about III 2017 is it can
literally be whatever we can imagine it
to be because who knew that we were to
get some of the titles that we were
going to get limes are getting to be any
better it could be anything getting
that's why it's magic better
better and faster and faster and it's
becoming this thing where every single
year I'm like I have so many games to
play I don't know what to play there's
20 different games they're all
incredible yeah guys that sounds like
the perfect positive note to wrap up our
e3 live show here Thank You joven Shire
so your key thanks ray lasercorn for
joining me for this segment great to
talk with you guys and thanks to all you
folks at home for tuning in for
gamespot's co-op stage coverage it has
been a pleasure to have all our friends
on stage here talk about the discussions
and engage with you in the comments big
shout out to our crew for making this
all happen and let the gentlemen there's
a lot of e3 to still enjoy on gamespot
please be sure to check it out but for
now I'm Chris waters it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next year